[Musique]
la compagnie strasbourg
a démarré à plaisir sont sa carrière
dans l'immobilier puisque nous avions
réalisé en 1998 des quatre longues
plaisir puis nous avons implanté micky
puis nous avons implanté naquit et
besson que nous avons réalisé alpha parc
1 et alpha parquet de aux
clayes-sous-bois est en fait c'est le
dernier
la dernière étape je dirais mon grand
plaisir de la dernière étape de notre
travail puisque nous avons racheté le
vieux centre commercial des sablons et
nous avons décidé de réaliser un centre
commercial flambant neuf avec des
enseignes fantastique
[Musique]
nous sommes à la jonction entre la
partie galerie couverte est découvert et
la partie extérieure vous avez ici un
très beau geste architectural de janis
ranallo notre architecte avec cette
cascade cet escalier de jonction qui
relie les 1000 places de parking tout
sécurisées couvertes que nous avons
sinon aussi là vous avez la place des
restaurants avec le multiplexe et en bas
vous avez des commerces
gémeauxce aussi à une salle de très
belles salles de gym aux nerfs et qui se
terminent tout au bout par action avec
une plaine de jeux pour enfants qui est
gratuite
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]